today's topic today's topic everybody
wanted us to cover the andrew tate stuff
so i ended up deciding doing a little
bit of a deep dive to learn so i did the
research and the big thing that kept
coming up i saw ethan klein as a bunch
of other youtubers calling him a human
trafficker so i looked into it and i'll
be honest with you the evidence that
he's a human trafficker is extremely
flimsy
so
the the two tails or one
he ran away from the uk because he was a
human trafficker
guys
if you think that the police in the uk
really believe he's a human trafficker
how did he visit recently how did he
visit over the last few years and gone
back constantly okay let me tell you
something let me tell you something if
you're if you're suspected of something
serious right if they have hard evidence
you can't just willy-nilly re-enter the
country whenever you want okay
look it's just so stupid no no
and then the other one was like
none of this works like that there's two
sides of the story i'm gonna give you
both sides the girls side of the story
romania is that she was lured by
andrew tate's brother come down there
okay because he was telling her i'm in
love with you and i'll leave your
boyfriend so she left her boyfriend
supposedly went all the way to romania
for this guy that she met online that
she said she fell in love with and then
he locked in a room and tried to put her
into human trafficking supposedly that's
the story the other guy's entertaining
his brother they say no that's not what
happened that's not what happened at all
this girl was out here partying wanted
to live the best life was cheating on
her boyfriend her boyfriend found out
through one of the live streams because
he saw her and he's a fan of the show
and so he ended up calling to her and
she claimed at that moment that she was
being held against her will so they call
the embassy the people make a fuss
online all these cops show up they
arrest the guy they go through all the
evidence they look at the cctv footage
see her walking in and out of the
compound however she wants and they end
up deciding we're not going to file any
charges is not going any further than
that
what evidence do you have
when you guys speak with shut certainty
when you put these labels on people and
they haven't been convicted of any crime
they haven't even been charged there's
no evidence really coming out that
proves it how can you so confidently
call this person that
and my issue when i see goobers doing
stuff like this the same way when that
girl was accusing fresh and fit or
whatever okay is that when you guys prop
up these lies or these unsubstantiated
claims about people that you hate
and it turns out that the evidence
behind it is flimsy you start to look
uncredible all your other criticisms of
him get thrown out the window because
you're hell-bent on throwing [ __ ] mud
to the water see if it sticks you can
hate him you can find him he's
deplorable you can say a lot of his
opinions are [ __ ] stupid and not even
agree with you on some but when you prop
up these lies you lose me
and you lose a large audience that you
could have otherwise convinced in
different ways via argument but you're
too lazy you're too [ __ ] arrogant to
just be like i don't know what he is but
i'm not going to repeat this until it's
confirmed you can't do that
and what kills me is i'll see people
repeating this thing recently ethan
klein and his company got accused of um
what was it mistreating employees
creating a super toxic toxic work
environment at teddy fresh or whatever
people were using all kinds of stuff
and he's like why do you guys believe
this why you guys
you're doing the same thing you don't
see the irony you're doing the same you
don't see the irony no am i crazy that
you expect to be given the benefit of
doubt but you don't record that to
anybody else okay
go ahead and the thing that happened is
i always i always come back with this
point but that's really what pisses me
most when that happens whenever you lie
about someone like that i understand
that can be fueled by hate you don't
like the person you don't like what he
does and everything and stuff and you
yeah he has but
they took michael max's quote too
seriously by all means necessary so
you're trying to put him down by all
means but the thing that happened is
that those means can actually arm the
actual victims
people actually claiming that are
suffering for things from things like
that when they come out they're like man
maybe that's a
maybe that's not a real story and that's
the thing the by all means necessary
thing
calm down man
calm down if you ain't got enough to put
someone down don't put the person down
what would you want to put the person
down want to out the person or whatever
do that but on bay based on false thing
the other thing that you got you're
gonna prop it up to make it a thing and
be able to sound more credible at the
end of the day you don't
especially if we have evidence that it's
not yep
remember what happened to justin bieber
when an egg account accused them of
doing this and that and whatever
and he had to come out with receipts
saying i was this and i was there i was
there with that person that i never even
saw this i never even saw that person
all this sounds super sus an egg account
yeah you took
down
what paper took that took that
claim
propped it up and said oh it's juicy and
then all in the name of juice i don't
know how you do your stuff if it's just
for the click for the first for the
first news you know what i mean oh
let's be first on the news it's easy to
be first on the news when you invent the
news i'll say this to the claim that he
somehow beats women and they have it on
video i watch the video okay it's
clearly some kind of bdsm click but if
you don't believe me the woman in
question in the video is found in a
subsequent video right afterwards after
all the outrage and she's just sitting
behind children be like listen next time
do it harder because i want you to do it
properly because last time you act like
a little [ __ ]
now
hello everyone um i just wanted to say
something about the video that's been
released recently about me and my
ex-boyfriend andrew tate andrew is my
still great friend what you guys saw on
the video it's just what we used to do
it was just pure game he's a great guy
he will never hurt anyone
unless he's fighting
the people that are claiming that they
see the videos or the articles or the
receipts are the same people that watch
your receipt at best buy
or costco sorry yeah mm-hmm all right
all right you're fine you didn't did you
actually watch the video did you
actually watch the receipt items by
items or you saw that it was a video and
you said hey if they say that it was it
was there it must be true and you just
went by it
it's nonsense so if you want to willy
nilly call him a criminal fine but just
understand you're spreading fake news as
far as what we have available right now
so let's move on to the more opinionated
stuff
the stuff where he says my girl has an
only fan she paid me 80 because that's
mine she is my girl and she is now
giving away some of the most private and
intimate parts of her body to the
internet those parts of her body belong
to me effectively because she's my woman
that's the whole point of being with
somebody so to be pretend to do that
make a bunch of money and give me
nothing is i find that disrespectful i
would i would sooner tell her look
you're not doing only fans and she would
or stuff like um but if you cannot
provide as a man if you are not
competent she will lose respect for you
and eventually she will leave or
i'm going to be able to sleep around but
my girl can't
because
i'm the man i'm superior she's inferior
okay you have all these different
opinions you hear them repeat all this
stuff me when i hear this stuff you know
what it sounds like to me this is the
high value man 2.0
this is dating for the ultra rich
you don't like it you don't have to like
it you want to see his misogynistic
that's fine you want to see his
inappropriate whatever that's cool
but rich people live like that that's
why bill clinton could go around get his
dick sucked in the oval office and his
wife stayed beside him that's why
politicians are having all kinds of
weird-ass orgies in washington and
nobody says nothing it's why saudi
princes are flying out
all these haram women while they got
wives with three kids at home so they
can turn them into porta-potties it's
because they got bread we don't have to
like it we don't have to say it's
acceptable we don't even say it's okay
but if they're agreeing to do that and
if these women want to buy into that
because let me tell you there's a lot of
instagram thotties who will accept these
terms because they get to be with a dude
who's a baller and takes care of all the
fans they don't care
he can sleep around i can't they accept
that as long as i'm taken care of
my man who's taking care of me
can
live his life like how he deserves
who am i to say anything who might tell
these people how they can't or can't
have the relationship that they
consented to and so long as they're not
telling everybody else you have to live
this way what the [ __ ] do i care and i
never understood the obsession with this
high value man let's talk about the hive
99 of you watching will never fall in
this tax break
you'll never get to achieve that level
you'll probably never live that
lifestyle and it's okay i'm not shaming
nobody it's fine but why are we so
obsessed with talking about these people
and how they do they dating like i would
never [ __ ] you were never invited you
can't even apply and what if it was my
relationship nobody asked you
go be a regular ass person we can talk
about that stuff this is a different
conversation but nobody wants to be a
regular ass person
nobody wants to be a regular ass
[ __ ]
nobody
wants to be called you're regular
you know how many girls that tell me oh
yeah i would do this i got one of my
friends
i gotta what about fred when we had the
whole fresh and fish [ __ ]
and she was talking some [ __ ] and she's
like yeah i could go out there and find
me myself a hot man like a rich man and
i'm like
i told her
[ __ ] you're 35.
no you can't
the odds aren't great you're average
you're you're odds are you're average i
told you you're average she's like what
i'm like your average here
here
here
you want to go to plastic town at 35 and
find your rich husband you're not what
they're looking for
boo boo your your app it's and it's okay
it's okay if we talk about the top
models and [ __ ] like that [ __ ] i'm
average
i'm fine with that
been averaged my whole [ __ ] life
i'm not fishing for compliments i'm just
saying it's fine
it's fine
i have to work on all this
being average it's fine
you don't have all this light on you you
do what you got to do some of y'all are
average at best
not talking about just you ladies
talking about men too
average
there are more
montreal is one of the cities with the
most beautiful woman
and the most average guys
average
guys here don't even think you're going
to be high value most of you
99
of you
me included
average
average
yeah
feels good man that's most of you
i traveled
i've seen y'all
average
calm down it's fine
but i know you guys are intrigued with
the living the live vision that's like
what people aim for you know what i mean
big expensive cars big houses big discs
big that you know i mean chain big
hair big everything big you know i mean
everything
most of you are not going to say that
that's okay
a lot of you are lying for that a lot of
you are poor because you want to emulate
that it's fine
it's fine to be average yep and also
it's not just the ladies
even the guys who are obsessing over
some of this advice talking about having
their own harem it's a great pipe dream
most of you guys are never going to have
it you can level up your life in some
ways sure man
but but the whole thing of like i'm
gonna have a wife and three [ __ ] on
the side listen there's only so many
women on this planet
only so many men on this planet most you
guys are never going to experience it
okay there can't be 10 women for every
man that's not going to happen do you
know how so most of you guys are
watching stuff it's cool but i know
there's a lot of you are also delusional
about what kind of life you guys are you
guys are no you're not going to do that
okay do you mind how much money it takes
just to have a girl one girl
one girl that thinks like that now you
want to have three do you know how much
you're not gonna have it you're not
gonna have that life so
it's important to have that balance to
me
this is the
epitome of poor people window shopping
at the gucci shop
that's what you guys are doing you're
seeing the lavish lifestyle behind the
window you guys are all obsessing over
it most you guys are never gonna own it
you can get your knockoff versions all
right go buy your [ __ ] where you
cheat on your girl and try to convince
her to stay around because you know
cool that's your knockoff version that's
fine but you're not gonna achieve that
so my my honest advice on a lot of this
stuff stop obsessing with what the ultra
rich do in their lives and their data
like who cares
you want to look at it from the outside
and have a laugh about it cool all you
guys i wouldn't
it's not for you
it's not for you so that's pretty much
like my thoughts on this stuff i'll
probably pull up a few videos where he
says some individual stuff and we can
discuss those things but you know like i
think people are getting too caught up
in this high value stuff high value me
and stuff and it's like who cares
but then again
the opposite is
even more ridiculous what is the advice
from other people that are not in this
eye valley stuff it's even more
ridiculous i understand why people
converse to that but yeah they do need
i understand why they convert to that
because the the other opposite like the
opposite is not
it's not better but they need to slack
up a bit of that because
there's two sides to it right there's
the ultra ridiculous stuff which is like
the rules are like i have 20 women and
and she only has one man right there's
that stuff right that's for the ultra
rich the people obsess over that but
it's really not that there's the other
side of the advice which leads to like
physical fitness goals improving your
financial situation getting your own
place understanding how to start talking
to them that stuff is very useful okay
and i'm not mad at that stuff
but that's not where the focus is put
the focus is generally put on the other
side yeah so
that's important to know
it's just like religion
go ahead it's a religion
be a good person
help one another help you love each
other yeah
hate gays
you know what it is
yeah there's all this good stuff but
there's always a you know there's a
[ __ ] up extreme dead ass you see all
these guys like buying the nicest lambos
spending all this money boozing it up
with the ladies taking all kinds of
stuff smashing left right and center
having kids out of wedlock doing all
this crazy [ __ ] right
and i laughed because the same dudes who
do all this stuff and do all this
high-value bread pill nonsense [ __ ]
there's the same dudes who's also
preaching like how religion is fantastic
spiritually super important religion
islam also my breath the very stuff you
guys engage in and represent and try to
encourage are the antithesis of the
religions that you also uphold so that's
always one dichotomy that makes me
chuckle you're like brother just stop
bringing up islam stop
you're not about it the way you live in
your life has nothing to do with that
everything is haram
that's a that's a whole other story i
just love the way the fact they bring up
religion to get conservative people to
buy in but it's like bruh your values
are nothing religious or conservative
but i digress let us know what you guys
think in the comments below we want to
hear from you